Patrick
[Musique]
bonjour
bonjour bonjour
je veux
aller plus loin
et
ça je peux le comprendre mais
par contre moi j'ai toujours mal
toujours pas vacciné
20.000 par jour aujourd'hui
oui mais ça fait plus longtemps
presque de passe vaccinal moi je
regrette cette procrastination parce
qu'on va venir on va venir parce que les
Français qui aujourd'hui se voit imposer
la troisième dose pour obtenir leur
passé militaire mais pourquoi moi
pourquoi moi qui a été voilà aussi j'ai
envie de légitime avec le besoin de la
France de sécurité sanitaire et je me
retrouve à devoir me justifier de plus
en plus pour pouvoir obtenir une vie
sociale normal
forcément
dans ces cas-là je pense pas qu'on ait
raison trop tôt c'est surtout les autres
qui ont
depuis trop longtemps depuis trop
longtemps
[Musique]
il m'a dit non il n'y aura pas
aujourd'hui
enterrement de débattre sur le sujet
mais en tout cas c'est une bombe à
retardement sanitaire une expression que
j'ai déjà utilisé régulièrement et je
crois qu'elle est elle est juste on ne
pourra pas continuer à demander plus
d'efforts à une partie des Français en
mettant de côté une autre partie des des
Français donc oui je suis pour avec mon
boulot obligation universelle président
Populaire d'imposer je pense que le
temps le rattrapera le temps le
rattrapera avant le présidentielle et
que donc chacun sait qu'il y aura un pic
en janvier que donc c'est à ce moment-là
que les décisions devant être prise donc
vous êtes toujours pour la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous y compris pour les
cinq 11 ans si c'est la Haute Autorité
de santé valide le principe notre
proposition était de Louane on était
pour les plus de 12 ans mais on est pas
bien on va bien chez les jeunes de 5011
ans
les 1000 pour 100 1000 les 1000 pour 100
mille alors que nous nous sommes pour
les adultes entre guillemets nous sommes
à 354 sens un peu plus de 400 de mon
département du Nord déjà on a passé la
barre depuis 400 ans donc on voit bien
que le, ça pue le plus chez les jeunes
qu'ailleurs le problème c'est que chez
les jeunes il y a beaucoup de
symptomatique
mais il porte, c'est qui donc il
contamine les adultes donc notamment en
premier lieu leurs parents ou les amis
de leurs parents quand il y a une
amicale chez les uns et les autres donc
tu risques pour les enfants pour les
tout-petits les pas du tout évident
compris par contre ce genre de mesure ça
va ça va est-ce que ça va pas être plus
difficile
de la vaccination pour les enfants
[Musique]
finale pour les 5 ans 11 ans mais pas
l'obligation voilà permettre aux parents
finalement j'ai choisi parce que quand
on touche
plus fort
[Musique]
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet sur la
faisabilité de cette 3e dos pour tout le
monde Destiny janvier puisque c'est
l'échéance du gouvernement est-ce que
les colis sont suffisamment est
suffisamment préparer
à fond
et
donc
en fait on a beaucoup de stock
quartier des gens qui ont eu deux
injections de fizer qu'ils moi je viens
d'avoir une troisième est de la même si
je veux pas ce serait bien légitime mais
je mange une petite fille qui est on me
dit que le moderne à peut être tout à
fait utiliser en 3e est-ce que vous
pensez que les gens ont confiance en moi
j'ai deux fois je préférais être
voilà
après si on
a la même écouté j'essaie de faire
confiance
Parlement
finalement le gouvernement
qui prolonge le délai de livraison de 12
à 14 semaines c'est
sûr
[Musique]
mais bon
rappel inscrire finalement je bois qui a
eu un arbitrage je m'en félicite je ne
sais pas à quel niveau a été donné
l'arbitrage mais certains pour dire
c'est un coup politique sûrement en
direction de l'électorat de gauche mais
moi vous savez ce qui m'importe si
[Musique]
tout va bien
pour obtenir
pour avoir le
en France ils sont obligés de partir en
Espagne ou en Grande-Bretagne pour
pouvoir
obtenir
chanson
d'une rencontre que le
manifestement préfère le Parlement
sagesse et bien dans ta sagesse j'espère
que le Parlement au bout du bout
adoptera je t'explique et progressif et
que nous avons toujours soutenu autre
proposition du moment où est-ce que vous
en êtes du droit de vote à 16 ans vous
êtes toujours sur ce créneau ou non
seulement non mais on va déposer on a
déposé une proposition de loi qui est
porté par notre collègue qui sera
examiné cette semaine donc oui nous
sommes favorables à 16 ans mais comme
étant le fruit d'une évolution
d'une mobilisation de l'Éducation
nationale sur une vraiment une éducation
civique qu' est-ce que
ça servirait de vote à 16 ans si je vais
dans votre sens on pourrait dire ma puce
je n'ai pas pourquoi pas le reporter à
21 ans non je pense pourquoi baisser à
16 parce que toutes les études montrent
en tout cas les spécialistes
plus en plus les jeunes plus ils
deviennent et citoyen responsable mais
dans le temps position de loin il y a
pas que le vote à 16 ans à l'école je
travaille à l'école
[Musique]
à la politique
table matières enseignées
au travers de pas j'ai fait aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ça montre bien qu'il y a un problème
problème culturel il faut lutter nous
pensons en conscience que le temps que
c'est une bonne réponse sur le droit des
étrangers cette fois on se connait des
efforts souhaite que ça soit inscrit
dans le programme pour le moment ce
n'est pas le cas vous ne connais pas
exactement programme est-ce que vous
aussi vous dit il faut absolument que ça
fait
deux fois
mais François Hollande
[Musique]
donner un signe en direction de ces
populations qui sont là depuis 10 ans 20
ans 30 ans 40 ans 50 ans parfois et qui
n'ont toujours pas le droit de vote aux
élections locales
[Musique]
que nous aurions dû le faire depuis bien
longtemps
en tout cas
aujourd'hui
sur ce chat mais d'abord
Valérie Pécresse annuler le sien pour
des raisons de sanitaires
est-ce que c' est responsable
de tenir un meeting
d'abord c'est un c'est une grande
réunion publique
[Musique]
en
oui
répondre nous prendre le pas sanitaire
nous on dit j'ai la colique il y aura
des masques donc nous voilà toute
personne qui viendra dans ce sera pas le
cas à Villepinte le weekend merci de
décisions de politiques
publiques
je pense qu'elle veut prendre un peu de
temps je le ferai
pas
de
la
République
portera sur un message sur le sur quelle
estime être la République au sens du
terme à celle qui n'exclut pas celle qui
ne considère pas l'étranger comme étant
un danger potentiel et avec aussi des
réponses sur le plan social puisque ce
qu'on ne dit plus rarement c'est que
Monsieur Macron elle s'était engagé à
faire baisser l'extrême droite dans ce
pays au bout de son quinquennat la
réponse est totalement un verre ce qui
veut dire que la politique notamment
sociale qui a été mené a été source de
fracture marqué par la clé des gilet
jaune mais sur ce site d'incompréhension
avec la crise sanitaire et que cette
peur dans l'avenir se traduit
malheureusement par des vols en
direction de le meeting de dimanche à
Perpignan c'est l'entrée effective réel
d'Anne Hidalgo dans la campagne
présidentielle où c'est une dernière
piqûre de rappel c'est la fin après
campagne
vraiment commencé je reprends
il a été un moment fort il y a le
meeting de lancement de la campagne sur
le meeting voilà avant les fêtes très
très concrètement il y aura la pose du
confiseur pour tout le monde à la
campagne commencera le 10 janvier
dimanche
à la fin du mois de janvier
[Musique]
mais j'ai toujours dit que la gauche
gauche martifer en terme de résultat
électoral donc
aujourd'hui
à gauche
[Musique]
et concert nous avons dépassé vous savez
je peux pas vous donner le chiffre exact
mais il augmente tous les jours et
l'augmente tous les jours j'ai encore
reçu de
la vente de votre émission
c'est tout de suite et ça continue en ce
qui veut dire que
mais j'espère que j'espère pour vous
qu'ils auront
non
clairement non
[Musique]
mais
il faudra
pour dire comment on
est
à gauche
[Musique]
processus similaire à souder République
République
il y a pas eu d'accrochage je vais
plutôt du respect entre les candidats
comment faire écouter nous avons
effectivement chacun a bien compris
mais
[Musique]
je pense que
c'est
sûr
[Musique]
qui
chante du campus sera prêt à quel moment
au meeting de fin janvier à janvier
bien sûr mais chaque chose en son temps
non pas du tout enfin janvier je pense
que ce sera pas encore quand il va
[Musique]
mourir
soyez patient viendra en janvier
[Musique]
j'ai envie de dire et voilà vous n'avez
rien à faire ici nous vous sortons ça
arrive dans tout le weekend et moi j'en
ai vu dans les meetings du Parti
socialiste ce qui s'est passé et
totalement scandaleux l'énergie
l'énergie de l'extrême droite on
montrait malheureusement la pire des le
pire des visages et je condamne
fortement cette cette agression qui est
vraiment indigne pour une démocratie
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]